hello everyone and thanks for coming for
this talk so without much further Ado I
am not here to change your mind about
what serial you have and this is just
going to be a use case for understanding
AI explainability
so let's get started what can you expect
from uh to take away from this talk is a
basic introduction to explainability uh
keeping in mind that all of you are
coming from different backgrounds so and
different expertise levels so a basic
introduction then how are explainability
and interpretability different and I've
written a small piece of code a linear
regression model to show how sharp
values and line values can help you
understand other how features are
affecting the model prediction
this is about myself and feel free to
connect on LinkedIn and Twitter my PhD
specialization is in data privacy but
ethical am and Ai and mlops is something
that I'm working on now
foreign
so you have ml models working everywhere
behind recommenders even behind games
and uh while some of you would be
involved in development some of you
might be handling the business side so
uh uh we know that ml models they are
opaque they are notorious for that
they're very different from conventional
software in that sense so uh how is this
opacity hurting the stakeholders
involved so first of all if I'm talking
about stakeholders if you take the
example of a model that's working for
maybe a loan credibility score
so a model would predict that whether
the particular person they should be
allowed to take out a loan or not this
is their score this is the confidence
that they should be allowed to take out
the loan and uh this model it would be
used by a manager sitting in a bank
it would also be used by a scientist
just to test out what they have devised
so uh a certain level of results they
make sense to the data scientist but
where uh loan manager is sitting they
have different set of expectations they
would want to know that okay what were
the factors that made one person
undesirable for a loan and the other not
so uh there might also be some defective
correlations between the features in the
data set
and definitely difficulty in debugging
because uh any one of us who has
developed an ml model have been through
that pain that it is very difficult to
debug sometimes that okay on paper the
data felt good it was intuitive it
should have worked but why okay I'm also
getting a good accuracy but then what
about a certain score of what about
Recall why am I getting so many uh
problems why is my prediction not
working fine in production it was
working fine in the training so all
these uh list of debugging hell that
happens through explainability then loss
of control so uh you have an opaque
model at hand
um some of the workings of inner
workings of the model
they need to be understood uh to control
any side effects that might happen in
production so to keep a watch on that
also you can use explanations uh for
instance you might also be uh like some
feature might have crept in while doing
the modeling you didn't notice it and it
started to make impact on the model
predictions again it would smile into a
loss of control over the performance of
the model
then bias bias is again a very big
concern when we're talking about
modeling
especially if we want to see a certain
feature which is not working which is
working starts to work against or in
favor of a certain demography so
explanations would also help you with
that
uh all these are like lot of words but
when we see the code maybe then it would
get more clearer a definitely serial
data set wouldn't have anything to do
with bias
so a major diversion may also happen
between the model performance and the
vision the business Vision or the
research problem that you've started out
with so keeping an eye on the model
performance in view of the feature
attribution helps in making your ml
model uh less opaque it is no longer a
black box now
so practical explainable AI Solutions
should focused on different should focus
on different stakeholders as I had said
earlier whether you are developing it
whether you are using it whether you're
making business decisions based on it
you need to be aware of the Dynamics
that are happening behind the
predictions on the classifications
so again this slide it has a lot of
information let's just focus on the
right part first so what do explanations
look like
uh on the right side we have uh the
explanations for a vgg 16 model some of
you might be working with computer
vision so uh there are images where they
might have different color genres they
might have a lot of happening in them
they might be very noisy or they might
be blurred but somehow our computer
vision models they are so smart they
know like okay if this is a Chihuahua
and this is a cat so how does that
happen and whether this is a stop sign
when you are training a model for an
only Auto driving car so how does that
happen the explanations that we generate
they look like these uh heat maps that
we can see the blue and the followed by
light blue and yellow Parts these are
highlighting the very important features
of each image which uh tell the model
that okay focus on this area this is the
part of the image that is helping me
decide whether that's a palm bench
whether that's a street sign a stop sign
or whether that's a chihuahua
and this also reminds me of that funny
meme where we have muffins so again you
can see why it happens because if you
see the middle image of the Chihuahua uh
if it were a muffin it was very it would
be very easy to confuse the model
on the left side I have a textual form
of the explanation
so uh how does it look uh if we are
generating an explanation report
um and a margin which is classifying
vegetables you might have a potato you
might have a broccoli and you might have
lemon so uh the label would be the
output will be like this is an image of
a broccoli that is the label the output
of the model and the text in Orange is
the explanation so this is the reason
why the model it model said that this
particular vegetable it's a broccoli
because it is green has a flowering head
and nothing stem with small leaves so it
is backing uh the outward saying it's
broccoli by these justifications
so coming to how explainability and
interpretability are different
where we talk about explainability it is
seeking to give a human understandable
form
whereas interpretability Works more on
the model level
so what you can do you can see the
change in the output for specific
changes in the input
for instance let's take this example
where a train model will decide whether
the human kid would like a particular
food item or not and what are the food
items they have been given we have
french fries and we have given them
broccoli
it's common sense but okay there are
some kids who like broccoli so let's
just say this is what we taught the
model that uh it was given one input set
X1 which said that the underlying potato
that was used was a underlying vegetable
was a potato it was fried and the
spiciness was low and human kid was
happy
then second instance was uh the
vegetable was broccoli it was steamed
and the spiciness was low
which gave us a sad kid
so the model was changed this way on a
large data set training data set now how
would interpretability would help you so
let's say uh we want to continue with
broccoli itself but how do we make the
human kid happy
so uh the model took the vegetable the
cooking method and the spiciness low
spiciness is is the constant so uh let's
see if we do a cooking method we change
it to fried so a fried broccoli with low
spiciness it would be predicted as a
happy emotion based on how the model was
making decisions the model had been
trained and it is using this input set
and checking okay how do we change the
output which is the emotion of the kid
so these were all about uh what I have
to talk about the introductions let's go
through the code
is my screen visible
disc
so it's a very simple uh okay thank you
so it's a very simple linear regression
model that I trained on serial ratings
data set that I originally took from
kegel.com
so I can also share the link to this
collab notebook later on after the end
of the talk so you can change the things
around this and the data set is hosted
on GitHub my GitHub so it's all
available for your use
so what is the data set about there's
the name of the serial the manufacturer
so we have certain manufacturers
associated with the serials this type
was a gold or hot cereals these are
specific to the US these cereals the
data scientist specific to that then the
calories per serving for the cereal the
protein in grams fat in grams and other
ingredients that we see on the boxes of
our cereals sometimes it's already there
uh other important features were the
weight that's there in one serving and
it's in ounces and
the serving the cups is linked huh okay
a number of cups in one serving and your
output is the rating that people had
given so it could also be an average of
the survey that was taken so these are
the ratings given to each of the serials
so I just checked what who are the
manufacturers they also needed to be
changed to numbers
and there were some garbage values like
minus one which I changed to a zero
so I was curious about what's the factor
like how is a manufacturer changing
things but I let it be for this run
maybe when you get your hands on the
notebook you can remove that and try the
code again
so
this is the distribution of the ratings
so apparently average rating was the
most reported value for the Target
and okay people are not too happy about
serials so a rating of 90 is very less I
think only one person reported that
so I changed all the strings to numbers
type is zero one one I let golden hot
serial types remain because that's fine
there were only four uh thought types
others were cold
the manufacturers and we would not be
using the name so I removed the name
because I didn't want to consider name
as one of the features for the model
so this is where we train we
declare the model linear regression
model we train it and we make
predictions so this is a very easy piece
of code it is very basic linear
regression model
and somehow we got a very good
performance
so not bad
and okay this is a linear regression
model and you must have you must be
aware that we have coefficients
associated with each of the features so
why do we need to make things
complicated why do we need explanation
anyways we have these coefficients they
tell they have the direction as well the
negative ones and the positive ones how
what how they influence the prediction
so why we need the explanations
so coefficients are fine but if we take
the weight the weight feature as I had
mentioned earlier the weight had been
provided in ounces
so
right now the coefficient is minus 0.04
now what happens if we move to another
country we try the serious data set for
another country they have the metrics
system which wants to measure the weight
in grams
so one ounce is
28.35 grams
so how would the coefficient be modified
then it would be divided by 28.35 and
our new regression coefficient for V
would be this
now this is a very small value but this
should not mean that uh
yeah but this should not mean that
weight was not important
okay this is another example I wanted to
put
or if we take another example for
instance it was a housing a data set
housing price data
I said and it it was given in years and
it would have some in coefficient
attached to it now uh if we change the
data set to uh the daily measurements
instead of yearly we go to the Daily
granularity then again the coefficient
would change we would divide it divided
by 365 because 365 days are there in one
year so again the coefficient would
differ but that should not mean that the
importance of the feature is changing
with respect to model performance
so let's get started with the
explanations
sharp is based on sharply values and it
works on global level so if we consider
the whole data set shaft scores would
tell the importance of features with
respect to the whole data set the model
performance
so the intent the concept behind sharp
values is that it's based on Game Theory
and just like in Game Theory a player
can join in and they could leave we
could have just one player at a time or
100 so the performance of a game and how
it's it's going to progress a certain
player would have a like uh they would
be contributing to the game on their own
individual level and we have the game on
the whole so similarly we have a model
performing on the whole and your
features are the players that are
joining in and leaving and we see how
the model is performing with each of the
features importance when they are taken
away and when they are added
another example that was given in the
Google AI explainability white paper it
was about a firm which are three
employees ABC and okay it was time for
appraisal and the company had certain
Revenue that it had gained in the past
year and ABC had joined uh like a couple
of days apart
so this time of appraisal was it had to
decide that who had contributed best to
the revenue so a sharply model can be
constructed in this way that what was
the revenue gain when only a was there
when only B was there and when only C
were there like he was there BNC were
not there b was there a and CR were not
there C was there and a and b were not
there so what were their contributions
to the company Revenue
so on similar lines we develop sharp
scores for the features
so these are the partial dependence
plots that are very typical to Sharp
values
and here I am considering calories first
sugars you can plot uh dependence plants
for each of the features
so the direction of the plot
it is decided by in what direction the
feature is impacting the performance
so this is some helpful text that I had
put in for your reference
so this line is the expected model value
okay the overall value
and this is the average value of the
median for the fiber percentage because
I plotted The partially panels for the
fiber feature
in this case the horizontal line is for
the sugar values
sugar feature
so this is your dependence plot uh here
we can see that it's a linear
relationship in some data sets this
might not be a linear relationship it
could be a very volatile graph as well
so this intersection is the part where
we calculate the sharp score but uh
let's get to this when we see the
waterfall plot of the sharp scores
so this is what you usually see on
systems that are giving you sharp scores
for the features and how they are
attributing to the model performance so
if you just turn your head to the right
it would look like a histogram but the
thing is we have directions attached to
this so colors are not intuitive but red
means that the attribution is positive
that it is adding to the model output
while the negative ones they are not
adding to the model output and there is
a sharp score is the magnitude to which
they are not adding to it so we have a
model output that we start with for all
the red features they are adding to it
the model output well the blue ones they
are decreasing it so we are just going
towards the final model output
in this case
64.82 it was the average rating
and these were the values of each
feature and how they had contributed to
the prediction of value 64.482
over here I've written 14 because uh
there are 14 features here
so this was about global explainability
where we are talking about the whole
data set the whole table including all
rows
lime is used for local explainability
when you would like to focus on a
specific rope
so again this piece of code is there a
train and explainer so let's take a
average value like average reading value
so this is just one instance where the
rating was 58.3 it is somewhat average
reading for a serial
and this is where lime again it's like a
waterfall you can see in this case
sodium calories vitamins they played an
important role
while overall when we talked about
global one carbs and sugars played a
very important role followed by sodium
and fiber somehow it was not helping the
ratings
so for an average our eating
these would be the feature values for
one if you consider it as a single row
in a data set foreign we are just
focused on that one row where the
feature values were these
and these were their attributions
now let's come to a lower rating of
37.06 again this is just one row of the
data set where the rating was not so
good
so these are the feature values for the
case when the rating was not so good
so these are very specific instances of
the data set and sometimes they also
help in pinpointing about performing
rows of where the output was not good
why it was not good these were your
feature values maybe you can check
against them
so again we have the attributions for
this very rating
carbs had a very positive impact
calories
maybe vitamins were there so maybe the
uh the person who gave the rating they
were a bit lenient with giving the
rating maybe they wouldn't have even
given 37 if it were not for the vitamins
then I took another random one
where I'm again it's like it's a random
row which I picked 53.32 and these are
the feature values
so I was also curious that what if the
serials they had their names with them
so what if there was a fruit component
in them
then how would the explanations change
so I just made another column with fruit
and they were like uh strawberry
flavored ones and with fruit bits ones
so all these cereals are marked as one
and the others are zero but the absence
of any fruit component
I again trained a linear model on it
linear regression model
okay this is absolutely fishy but again
we are concerned more with explanation
and we can see how
we can model performance later on
so now we have another feature fruit
okay regression says that okay it
doesn't have any impact on the model
output on the predictions whether your
serial has a fruit component or not it's
okay it's not affecting the ratings
but can we believe that let's see let's
look at the explanations
so again I do I plotted the partial
dependency plants
let's go to the waterfall to give a
better picture as you can see
fruit the sharp scoop of fruit is zero
so it means that whether the cereal had
a fruit component in it but maybe
raisins or maybe dried strawberries or
apples it didn't have much effect on the
reading that people gave to the cereal
so it is more to do with carbs which are
directly associated with the base of
cereals whether it's oat base or rice
based or wheat based carbs are
definitely there sugar is an important
factor so people probably prefer sweeter
cereals and they rate them higher okay
we like this cereal more because it is
sweeter sodium again is a taste
component so sugars and sodium they are
there with a very major positive impact
on the ratings
fiber not so much this might be due to
the fact that oat based seen as they are
not that popular as per my understanding
and rest values vitamins fat they have
some effect on that
but not fruit components
so you can check this notebook I also
implemented one lime explanation for the
fruitcase as well so again
it is retreating the fact that fruit
components do not have much effect on
the ratings
and let me just share the link to this
notebook on the chat so feel free to
make a copy of it and make changes to it
it's it would be great and please get
back to me if you see any any mistakes
or if I should have considered other
features as well
so can I send it to the studio chat
I'll just send it to your studio maybe
they can forward it yes I think what we
could do is to actually share it on uh
Discord as well that way yes
so this is what I have to present today
and sure thank you John so this is from
my side I have shared the link on the
studio chat as well if you would like to
forward and definitely on this card as
well so please questions
great thank you so much Kata for for
your time it was excellent I was very
curious about how lime and sharp
Compares in terms of explainability so
so that's that's a good good overview of
it
um I so uh the audience those who are
who are listening to this talk um feel
free to post your questions
um in chat in the YouTube chat I'll be
monitoring them and I can field any
questions together if if necessary
foreign
I have a question of my own
um if you don't mind me asking I saw in
your last analysis when you compare your
sharp results and the line results uh if
I recall correctly the carbs was
um among the high contributing factors
for uh for the selection but in shop but
but for lime I didn't see that it was
showing up could you like give some
explanation for that
oh this is for the
carbs
okay this is for a particular row but a
poor rating uh if I'm taking 37 as a
poor rating
uh these are the values of the feature
that were available for that particular
row
so carbs were in grams so it had very
low value of uh okay very less grams of
carbon carbs but the its impact on the
model output the prediction was high it
was towards the positive side
I think I was referring to the last
example that you had where you
introduced fruit as the additional
columns okay and then when you combat
the results yeah
in fact it was pretty much the same as
earlier what I was trying to communicate
was that uh that uh fruit components
they didn't play much role in the
ratings
I had hypothesized and this is what I
wanted to test that what makes us feel
popular that uh maybe the recent months
are the ones maybe Applejacks it's so
popular but is it because of the Apple
flavor or the raisin brand ones is it
because they are raisins so uh we cannot
say that okay adding raisins would as
such uh give us a good rating but
definitely people are going for Taste if
you see sugars and the sodiums they were
ranking high and they are contributing
to the ratings so we can maybe a Serial
which is nice and taste which has a good
texture so yeah actually because of
carbs so maybe then it would get a good
rating
okay if interesting all right there are
two questions from chat um I know this
uh
um post them up here so the first
question is by um
thanks you are mentioning uh computer
vision analysis I don't see them in an
analysis could you give some insight
into that
yes I did not take that example because
I wanted to use a very simple model and
that's why I did a linear regression
model but uh thanks for suggesting this
maybe I'll try something and post it on
my medium right on medium as well so
make a poster
is definitely it's a good use case for
computer vision as well uh especially if
we are talking about medical images and
if you're talking about x-rays or
retinal images uh you would definitely
know more but even in retinal images
there are certain components there are
veins that need to be considered for
whether the person is diabetic or not so
computer vision is definitely a very
good use case for explainability
great so thanks for thanks for that uh
there's a second question by crypto Pi I
will post it up here cryptobias can snap
be used to if I I assume that we use
evaluated RL or deep RL models
uh I've not used it yet I've just used
it on SIMPLE ml models
but if we have a internal State
associated with learning uh I wouldn't
give some answer out of the hand because
I've not tried it okay